un Vergel rico en biodiversidad el
pulmón del mundo que año año ve mermada
su extensión debido a la deforestación
ilegal en 2020 perdió
10.267 kilómetros cuadrados marcando un
récord histórico en el último año de
gobierno de Jair bolsonaros según
observadores nacionales una tendencia
que busca cambiar su sucesor Lula da
Silva con la vuelta de las redadas
antideforestación entre otras medidas el
trabajo de ong es como rioterra también
es clave en la reforestación
la fuerza de la destrucción es mucho más
grande que la de la reconstrucción
tardas años en recuperar un área pero
una persona con una máquina tarda
segundos en tirar todo al suelo
su trabajo se centra en plantar nuevos
árboles en granjas y zonas deforestadas
se enfrentan Sin embargo a los
asesinatos de activistas ambientales
según la organización global witness 342
entre 2021 y 2022 desde la organización
Black Jaguar apuntan también a otros
problemas
necesitamos la confianza de los
campesinos y necesitamos confiar en las
comunidades locales el otro problema
definitivamente es la necesidad que
tenemos de crear nuestras propias
infraestructuras
pese a ello insisten en la tarea de
ayudar a realizar el corredor de
biodiversidad de araguaya
es un proyecto masivo de reforestación
El corredor en sí tiene 2.600 km de
largo y 40 de ancho con la ayuda de las
comunidades las autoridades brasileñas y
la comunidad internacional esperan
conseguir sus metas para Ben Falls las
razones simple no enfrentamos un cambio
climático sino una crisis climática con
impacto global